hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the three
main divisions stoic philosophy was what
we translate as logic coming from tobblo
DK which could also be translated as the
art of reasoning the art of
argumentation the art of using words the
art of thinking things through so it's a
bit broader than what we normally talk
about today in terms of formal logic or
even necessarily informal logic as a
matter of fact they would extend to
incorporate dialectic rhetoric you know
all the areas on piste Amala G all the
areas that are concerned with these
sorts of issues and there's a tendency
when looking at Epictetus and even when
looking at what we possess a of stoic
authors to downplay this quite a bit say
it's not really that important now the
Stoics did in fact make some major
contributions in the history of logic
but that patinas is not one of those
people engaged in that so why is the
insisting in some of the chapters in
book 1 that it's really important for us
to pay some attention to this or asked
in another way why isn't ethics enough
it's already a lot of work just to study
FA
to figure out how we should realign our
desires and versions of this examine
ourselves and change things here and
there
why do we have to focus on logic and
there's a good answer from a stomach
perspective or at least several good
answers that epictetus is going to give
us and I'm going to conclude by bringing
up a passage it's two of my favorites
that talks about
Epictetus himself as a student when it
is teacher getting chewed out and it
will come to that I'll be the capstone
so we look at chapter 17 he says that
the rational faculty it is the one that
analyzes that's a term that's the way
we're translating it there the other
film this is a part of simple so this is
the activity that it does it's it's the
one that can can scrutinize can examine
can render judgment upon the other
faculties and indeed everything that is
involved in us doesn't mean that they
can do it across the board at all times
in a pure luminous self consciousness
the way that some people are worried
about but it can in fact what it turns
its attention of things it can think
about them and it can work upon this is
a term that we've seen in other places
and regards on metals arrogating or even
God is works it's as the is the tasks
that are being done
it is deeds it's another way of putting
it so the thinking faculty the reasoning
faculty really is quite powerful now how
does it stand then with respect to that
faculty does it just automatically work
the way it should sort of like plug and
play software no that's not the case and
you know look at the video on the
reasoning fact
the rational faculty to get more about
that it does need to be analyzed itself
and nothing else is going to do that is
the reasoning faculty where they sort of
reflexivity applying to itself that's
able to do that so how isn't going to do
that that's where it becomes very useful
to start looking at table key K at the
heart of reasoning whether our reasoning
is going well do we characteristically
make improper inferences if so maybe we
need to examine our own thought
processes are we taking in information
from sources that are probably not as
reliable as we would like to think that
they are why are we doing that these are
key questions and ethics by itself is
not going to provide the answers that we
need we require some sort of rigorous
examination that's provided by the art
of reasoning another issue that comes up
in 117 and also it in one chapter one
book one chapter seven we need to
examine and understand
what ethnic fetus is calling the
criteria you notice that I've got a
little K there that's not a misspelling
that's just a great spelling for it and
the criterion means some sort of
standard it's just translated as the
standard usually some standard for
determining things what are we trying to
determine
well one point seven makes us very clear
we need to develop the power capacity
for testing the true of the false not
just taking oh that's true that's false
how do we know how do we actually know
that's something that we think is true
is true how do we know that's something
that we think is false is false and
therefore has to be rejected we need
some sort of standards criteria for that
and uncertain you know mortality is like
that
matter when you're you know debating
about what you want to do in life you
know so it seemed to be ethical issues
you're going to start ending up in
quandary x' we're just having studied
ethics it's not going to be enough along
unless you have accompany it with with
some logic and the Stoics didn't do this
in their their training we need to be
able to decide between these these
things and be able to have good reasons
for the decisions that we're making and
so you don't have penises going to say
you know some some interesting things
like this you says what's the professed
object of reasoning to state the truth
will they make the false to suspend
judgments and doubtful cases is it then
enough to learn this alone well here's a
comparison is it enough for the man who
wants to make no mistake of the use of
money to be told the reason why you
accept genuine money and reject the
counterfeit that's that enough what else
is needed well the faculty that tests
the money and the genuine and the
counterfeit distinguishes between them
well that is you know the art of
reasoning that is the you know when we
say the art of reasoning we're not just
talking about something in a textbook
we're talking about a kind of
comportment that could be built into a
person's rational faculty and carry it
around with them
he says it's necessary to develop this
this power what else besides this is
proposed in reasoning you know and then
we can go on further and they can get
more and more complex but that's really
at the core of he also points out in 1.8
that argumentation in the hands of the
the weak those who have not trained
their faculties and those who are
uneducated
can be quite dangerous and you know we
see this all the time people giving all
sorts of arguments that on the face of
them look to be decent arguments with
decent lines of reason
but as soon as you examine them you see
the flaws of them and yet those people
don't see the flaws in them and they
think that they're good and not only
that that back to you that says they get
all puffed up with pride they can really
notice them and you know they become
quite dangerous to themselves and they
become quite dangerous to others so the
art of reason it really is important
from a stoic perspective now what I want
to close with is this interesting
anecdote that he tells he says well why
are we still indolent and easygoing and
sluggish seeking excuses whereby we may
have boy toiling or even late hours as
we try to perfect our own reason he says
if then I err in these matters I haven't
murdered my own father yeah my he says
where was there a father for you to
murder one thing have you done you ask
you committed what was the only possible
error in the matter indeed this is a
very remarkably to Rufus when he got on
my case that translated as that so
censure you got on my case for not
discovering the one admission of a
certain syllogism I said well it isn't
as bad as my burned out the capitalism
and then he said the admission here is
the capital or there are no other errors
than setting fire to the capital and
murdering one's own father uses to make
a reckless and foolish and haphazard use
of the external impressions the fantasia
that come to one or if able to follow an
argument or a demonstration or sophism
in a word to fail to see in question and
answer what is consistent with one's
position or inconsistent aren't these
error aren't these the sort of things
that will lead us into all sorts of
problems you're right it's not the same
thing as killing somebody or burning
down a building but it is making fun
events on the stakes and those small
mistakes and what seemed to be
inconsequential things put them in
another domain of ethics they can get
quite problematic so it's important for
us if we're going to
adopt this point of view to cultivate
the rational faculty and to do so in
some sort of written in a rigorous and
systematic way and that's what the
Stoics actually did in their own
practice